in 1986 Castlevania took players inside
Dracula's sprawling horrifying mansion
and gamers never look back now over
three decades later Castlevania isn't
just a major video game series it's also
an animated series a series of comic
books and the origin of an entire video
game genre and just like Vlad's Castle
Castlevania is full of secrets there's
much more to the game than whips and
vampires mysterious origins over 30
official Castlevania games have been
published and a few are even considered
to be some of the greatest games of all
time so there's no doubt that
Castlevania is an important franchise
and yet historians have no clue who
actually created the thing Koji Igarashi
castlevanias longtime producer and the
name most commonly associated with the
franchise didn't start working on the
series until 1997 Symphony of the Night
Castlevania doesn't have a real credit
sequence ending with a tribute to people
like Christopher B and Boris Karloff
Asst why don't we know who made this
game in the 1980s and early 90s Japanese
game developers used pseudonyms at the
behest of their bosses in order to make
it harder for rival companies to poach
talented staff members some historians
have tried to track down castlevanias
creator but having gotten much further
than the name hey Toshi ah Komatsu but
other than a handful of credits and
other Konami games nobody seems to know
much about it from the looks of things
mister ah Komatsu exited the game
industry in the 90s and disappeared if
he ever existed at all
beyond Nintendo the first three numbered
Castlevania games launched on the
Nintendo Entertainment System leading to
the impression that the series started
as an NES exclusive franchise except it
didn't only a month after the first game
debuted the second entry in the series
vampire killer arrived on Microsoft's
MSX computer as a Japan exclusive and
Nintendo also ran Castlevania in some of
their verses system arcade cabinets
there's also haunted castle castlevanias
first original arcade outing which is
regarded as a pretty terrible incredibly
difficult game with awful controls even
worse Simon Belmont only has one life
and you can only continue three times no
matter how many quarters you pump into
the machine it wasn't long before the
Belmonts and Friends broke out into
every system out there but even early on
Nintendo wasn't the franchise exclusive
distributor Bram Stoker's Dracula it's
pretty obvious that Castlevania was
quite a bit too Bram Stoker's vampire
magnum opus but just how much Konami
made Stoker's book part of the official
timeline in Castlevania bloodlines
according to Konami the books Quincey
Morris who helps Jonathan Harker kill
Dracula before succumbing to his vampire
induced wounds is actually a member of
the Belmont line in the game series
Quincey dispatched Dracula and went on
to Father bloodlines hero John Morris
Jonathan from Castlevania portrait of
ruin is Quincy's grandson it's not a
perfect fit however according to
bloodlines John saw Quincy murdered
Dracula when he was a kid and without
Harker's help as a storytelling device
linking Stoker and Castlevania raises
more questions than it answers as a
tribute to castlevanias primary
inspiration however it works just fine
Ella cards origins one of the most
popular characters in Castlevania is a
loo card Dracula's half vampire son and
the hero of Castlevania Symphony of the
Night a noble and fierce warrior who's
put his dad back in the ground and saved
humanity multiple times while everything
about his backstory reeks of classic
video games a low card like his old man
is actually lifted from older source
material well not as well known as 1931
s Dracula the film's second sequel 1943
son of Dracula is actually responsible
for a loo card in the film horse tower
Lon Chaney jr. plays the mysterious
Count Allu card who seduces a young
heiress with promises of immortality of
course a low car is just Dracula spelled
backwards
so even though 1943 wasn't great at
being subtle the name stuck animated
adventures Netflix Castlevania is the
first video game to film adaptation to
earn a fresh score on Rotten Tomatoes
with a rating of 90% but it's not even
the first castlevania themed cartoon in
1989 Deak entertainment produced a
Saturday morning cartoon called captain
n The Game Master and characters from
Castlevania played a major role Captain
n tells the story of a teenager named
Kevin Keane who gets sucked into his
Nintendo and faces off against villains
from various 8-bit video games including
deranged versions of punchouts King
Hippo and Metroid's mother brain along
the way Kevin gets help from Mega Man
Kid Icarus a sentient Game Boy and
castlevanias first leading man Simon
Belmont in Captain end
Simon is a vain adventurer who cares
more about his dashing good looks than
fighting evil which is a pretty
unfaithful adaptation as far as cartoons
go Dracula shows up as a reoccurring
villain and a loo card shows up in the
third season episode return to
Castlevania as a wisecracking teenager
with sunglasses a bat shaped skateboard
and an unhealthy obsession with rock and
roll
[Music]
it was pretty much the most cringeworthy
early 90s thing ever and thankfully that
version of a loo card quickly
disappeared and never returned
timelines you don't make almost 20 games
in 10 years without making a few
mistakes but there's one decision in
particular that Koji Igarashi wishes
that he could take back while developing
Symphony of the Night Igarashi developed
a series timeline for the developers to
use as an internal reference once it
leaked to a gaming magazine Castlevania
team decided to make it official
according to the timeline dracula
returns every 100 years
but unfortunately the official timeline
is so thorough that Igarashi said that
it hurt his creative process down the
line
explaining since dracula only appears
every 100 years we made the whole
timeline and ran out of places to put in
another game of course when continuity
gets too crowded you can just throw it
all out and start over
that's what Konami did in 2010 when it
handed a new developer the reins to
castlevania lords of Shadow which takes
place in an entirely different universe
where that game almost didn't happen at
all metal gears shadow in the late 2000s
Konami enlisted Mercury steam to create
a brand-new 3d reboot of the Castlevania
franchise the developers put together a
prototype and showed it to konami
executives but they grew nervous about
all the changes that were being made to
their classic franchise so they stripped
away the Castlevania branding and allow
development to continue lords of shadow
made its public debut at Games Con 2009
later that year Mercury steam showed the
latest version of lords of Shadow 2
Konami higher-ups which included Metal
Gear Solid Overlord had AO Kojima Kojima
loved it and asked the room why isn't
this Castlevania eventually Kojima
joined lords of Shadow is a producer and
though he later leave Konami Kojima is
uniquely responsible for the
continuation of Castlevania as we know
it thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
let's check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]